now you will need your calculator for
this so what are we trying to do well
let's just first rewind a little bit and
look at what the question says it says
solve for and then there's this weed
stuff here now we've seen inequalities
all the way back since 87 if I say
something like say X is greater than 7
that means it can be 8 9 10 11 a hundred
and a half five thousand whatever
anything as far as that if I said X is
less than 10 I could say 9 or 8 or 7 or
negative 10 but here I've got X between
two values so it's between naught and
360 so excuse me hay fever this means
I'm looking for values of X that are
around the circle right that's what a
nought to 360 years one full circle
we're not in triangle land anymore we're
thinking about these guys on the unit
circle which is why I'm going to just
nice and small up in the top right hand
corner here I'm going to draw myself a
Cartesian plane now do you remember and
this is actually an honest question like
do you remember did mrs. Bell mention
that that ringabel
okay so I'm gonna tell you what it is
now so this is a little skin here that
will help you use the unit circle
without drawing a unit circle okay
a st see a little mnemonic that we might
help you remember those in order is all
stations to central there are other
versions as well but that's the most
polite one now all stations the central
was it stand for if there's for all sign
10 and cause what does it mean in each
of these quadrants as I rotate around
okay the different ratios signed in cos
and tan they change from positive to
negative positive to negative think
about this for example cosine cosine
cosine is the x or y coordinate which
one is it on the unit circle it's the x
coordinate the way I remember it is it's
alphabetical
you know how x and y are alphabetical
will cause
Theatre in same theater also
conveniently alphabetical so if close
theta this is why it helps to be on time
so we can get going and spend time to
understand this cos theta is the x
coordinate right so if I'm on this side
of the unit circle
is the x coordinate positive or negative
on this side it's positive right because
that's all of my positive values over
here it's X's that's horizontal whereas
on this side you can see the COS values
the X values are negative right because
that's what the left hand side means for
horizontal okay so that's why you see
all of the trig functions for a Grigios
sine cos and tan they're all positive
here cos is also positive on this side
cos is negative on this side that's why
you don't see cos up here okay now think
about sine sine sine is the y-coordinate
right so that means above the x-axis
sine is positive does that make sense
because the Y values are positive
that's why sine is positive here in here
but it's not here or here that's why you
don't see sine here in here okay
lastly you tell me look at the diagram
where is 10 going to be positive which
quadrants the top right
oops top right and the bottom left so it
starts to get a little bit cumbersome to
call them top right bottom left top left
etc so we just number them we call this
the first quadrant the second quadrant
the third and the fourth okay curious
thing Y is one over there why do I start
like we write in English which starts
from from left to right and goes top to
bottom why am i starting over here on
the right-hand side there's a real
answer to this think back yeah okay so
it's sort of like a nice easy way to
start like this is all the positive
stuff so that's easier to work with
there's another reason though if you
think back to the unit circle when we
measure angles around where did we begin
do you remember
we start on the I heard it on the from
the origin we look at the positive side
right of the x-axis you remember that
and then we measure upwards and then the
unit circle sort of goes around does
that make sense so that's our starting
point that's why that's one and two and
three and four okay so now we can use
this scheme to help us answer these
questions okay underneath this I want
you to write down base angle I'll
explain what that means in a second okay
now sine x equals 1/2 there's some angle
X such that when you go sine of that
angle you get 1/2 now this is I picked
these numbers because they're the nice
convenient ones does anyone remember
what it is it's actually 30 degrees now
if you can't remember that's no problem
you have your calculator there right so
will your calculator out what I want you
to type in is sine the way we read this
is sine inverse of 1/2 and it will
faithfully return that back to you does
it say 30 so 30 right fantastic so if
you remember it then that's great but if
you don't remember the problem that's
why you have a calculator okay now then
the next question is have a look at the
first line and tell me where the sine is
positive or negative is this a positive
or a negative number it's positive okay
so sine X is positive that means that
out of these four quadrants I will find
an answer in two of them the the
quadrants where sine is positive okay is
sine positive in this quadrant it is
quadrant one is it positive in this one
it is that's what sine means so - what
about these guys not they're duds ok so
that's it I will find answers in those
two quadrants so I take my base angle
and I say what does it look like in this
first quadrant now what range of angles
do I get in quadrant one
you start at naught and you rotate all
the way up until 90 so not to name we
have a name for that starts with an A
what kinds of angles are not tonight
acute angles very good 30 degrees is an
acute angle so I just say 30 degrees now
when I go and have a look in the second
quadrant this is angles from 90 to what
where does it stop
180 we have another name for that angles
between 90 180 are obtuse
what's the obtuse version of 30 degrees
it's a hundred and fifty where do I get
that from it's it's the supplement it's
a hundred eighty degrees take away 30 my
base angle and that's it those are the
answers you can check if you got it
right just like every other equation
you've ever done by taking these
solutions and substituting back go ahead
punch in sine 30 and your calculator
should tell you nore point five try sine
150 and it also will give you nor point
five does that make sense
sine and cos are not numbers they are
functions so you might as well ask me
what does this square root equal to and
my answer would my question to you would
be square root of what square root of 25
is a number square root of 16 is another
number because the square root is not a
number it's a function you do it two
different things just like you do it to
X or you do it to whatever angle you've
got okay